um
i just maybe dion okay they're gonna go
full on because i was like in the back
of my mind i'm like maybe dion knows
that let's say when they play he has
difficulty against this particular
matchup let me just bring that against
him but no they're gonna go full ball on
their best choices so let's see how this
is going to play out this is going to be
i think
uh more aggressive dion we're going to
see a more aggressive deal than normal i
think if i had to make it before
let's see how it's going to play out
yep this
okay
nothing too risky from natural getting
lots of damage in there
trying to you know trying to get the
whole game in
i like what i see
hey people talking talking ish about the
forward four hey pretty good don't talk
it's nice we still couldn't move we got
it there you guys got a sorry pretty
good i think it's nice it still does
damn very nice
but there's some gin mines out there
just you know
playing some crazy stuff
down back forward nice searching for the
orbital gets this magic four
and looking for the shotgun right there
you see natural just go right back to
that same one two four string
teasing them with the electrics trying
to get them to swing on something but
you to be careful up close there's the
hill sweep gin
uh
gets the wall splat
down back four whiffs
teasing him oh there's a normal throw no
breakout
round three where you least expect it
damn okay let's see how you're gonna
stop okay more defensive start this time
damn what move is i don't even know what
move that was from leroy
oh gets the counter here
oh
legit every match hits at least one
electric just to let you know
every every match like yo just just
don't don't you forget about these
electrics bruh
i got the execution he's letting you
know
that was definitely an election okay
there it is
the wake up okay overheads
guess the war split again resetting his
damage
okay this should hit the wall okay in a
weird angle but it didn't roll off there
you go perfect
damn we're back to the final round okay
okay
natural had the lead throughout the
finals yeah
oh yeah
oh magic
magic
doesn't get the wall
stop goes for the low option didn't
block it
not big daddy kane out for the final
round again not getting any damage out
of it
getting chipped to death let's see if he
can save himself he's got the whole
pressure
the classic the
round closeout classic the one
down three
who would have thunk it it works man you
can't you can't hate it
the only people that hate it are the
people that eat it that's the problem
yeah that's absolutely true
like come on that's just the fact right
now
but yeah that was a good um return from
uh
from natural because in the beginning i
was like okay he's really got the
control and then dion was like no no no
but then right at the end brought it
back so
it's interesting how he can just like
keep himself he's constitutional in that
sense that he can just get that win so
hey i'll take it
i mean see what dion's gonna do yeah
yeah deanna i feel like is is really uh
on the ropes right now um
but
dion definitely when we were watching
him play earlier really did have like
the rebuttal down to her art like you
really still can play he can play a pace
slow enough to run and be himself back
in sets like this so it's not over just
yet and on top of that this is a loser's
side you can't afford to lose one more
match at this point while you're going
home
all right okay going back to the arena
okay
so yeah it's a pretty common pattern
with uh dion from
today that we see that he goes back to
arena again it's probably one of my
favorite stages as well
it's like that in an infinite that's
usually what i go for when i play i
actually now got the island paradise
that's kind of my new one
the soundtrack's too op yes it actually
is ridiculous
all right here we go okay
go in there smallest the wall carry has
been definitely in naturals favor
yeah i feel like naturals been getting a
lot more of the launchers a lot more the
counter hits to get these launchers and
dion gray is still just trying to find a
way to get any game started that's the
wall that's the round
damn this is
quick i'm surprised
oh nice slope harry
okay gets the wall again damage
[Music]
keep the walls played swings in the
middle of the one
that's not good
this could be his again you're dead yeah
the horsepot saved him yeah wow
round three go natural fight
naturals killing it right now
i told you every match they're going to
collect just to let you know
oh
oh boy
get a lot of mileage with this hermes
stance
oh yeah four crouch down four or four
just rocking like and
one for me one for you two
i dropped it
but against the reset it was a setup
dude calculated wow
and that is it for genuine gaming's dion
grey
wow he's out that is pretty hectic so
where would that put him in the rankings
that puts him equal fifth i think
uh at this level i think it is
so that means he gets an additional 70
points which gives him roughly 230
something so he's still in it so he will
be at the regional finals so